*inaudible unholy entrance*
How's it going, bros?
My name is Pewwwdiepie.
Today we're gonna play Google Feud.
But if only, I had a friend to play with.
PJ: heeeeyyy Felix, how's it going?
Oh wow, that was fast. *laughs*
PJ: I can come in slow if you want
PJ: What's going on?
Oh what were you doing there?
PJ: I just heard you needed a friend, I thought come to.. your rescue.
*laughs*
Thank you I appreciate that!
You want to play Google Feud?
PJ: Yeah let's do it man. Should I be taller?
*Awesome transformation music* PJ my mortal enemy!
PJ: What? I don't wanna fight.
we're going to fight it out.
Whoever wins this-
There are punishments involved.
Okay which one do you prefer?
nail art
PJ: Ooh beautiful nails... maybe
Would you like a tattoo perhaps?
PJ: *inhaling*
PJ: smells gewd.
or a hair- hairlights?
PJ: Why are you talking as if it's only gonna be me
*Pewds laughs*
PJ: Why are you saying that I-
THIS IS NOT RIGGED!
I promise!
Let's begin the game.
PJ will now explain the game
ahh............
PJ: click on the category
Yeah.
PJ: you have complete the google sentence.... thing
good.
OOHH
PJ: this game is?
So our goal is to guess what the right answer is.
we will get different points depending on which
if it's the first one or the tenth
option
PJ: alright hold on.
Yea
*Pewds laughs*
No.
PJ: no? I don't know
I mean- *fpphhss* yeahh
*pewds laughs*
PJ: Shiet!
Awwe- alright
PJ: I don't know- what? that's such a- who's who starts-
This game is awesome (no sarcasm intended)
WHUT??!!
pewds sighs of failure
PJ + Poods: So esey??
PJ: this game is so esey!
PJ: this game is rigged
a nipple...
a nipple..
a nipple.
You go ahead
ok yeah you think you got this yeah I
got this got questions
PJ: ok. can should i stop?
Yes...
PJ: Should I stop?
*Poods laughs*
rip PJ 2016..
PJ: should I stop
*masturbating*
*poods laughs*
PJ: come on, people have googled that. That is a very google-able thing
That is a google-able thing.
PJ: okay let's see
PJ + Pewds: WHHAT??!1!1!
PJ: because yeah you do need to stop
masturbating yeah you right now yeah
PJ + poods: right now the fuck are you doing put on
your pants huh
PJ: jesus..
This is always like "I won't stop dancing"
Fuck.
No.
What--kay
So what kay--
Okay, okay.
What?!
DRINKING! Of course!
PJ: Texting him?
We are SO... bad at this! (I'm bad at captions)
*poods laughing* PJ: Texting her?
Taking birth control?
Being vegetarian?
I-I like that being vegetarian is higher than eating meat.
Breastfeeding? *senpai looks at camera
How to get rid of your...
How to get rid of your husband?
*PJ in agreement* Pretty good.
No, you know what?
How to get...
*typing* of your zit.
Ahhh kay!
Yeah.
Pretty solid, pretty solid.
First point, PJ. Here it comes! :D
*rejected* XDD (LOL! GET REKT!)
Oh... *Poods faints, falling to his death*
This is... ridiculously hard.
Yeah...
I wanna know if you guys are
getting any points.
*typing 'husband'*
You can't steal mine! XD
Well, how will you ever know like what
could it have been?!
That's true. *laughs*
Th-Well.
*something XD* I'm pretty sure there's a reason? (IDK)
PJ: Shit!
Double chin should have been obvious!
PJ: Yeah. Poods: Period fast?!
Sister?
how are we not gotten a point so far PJ we're literally the worst because we suck
I've got one
ok is it possible to fly Pewds: I was thinking the same thing
ok nOOOOO. 8,000 points why would you google that
you fuckin idiot (good question)
PJ: is it possible to fly
Pewds: is it possible to fly?
no its not absolutely not
that is wanted to check up yeah
is it possible to
-extremely dramatic dark music-
yeah it's pretty good oh ok
why would why would anyone google that
..be allergic to water..?
time travel!
*types*
[a homosexual]
NO
What's it gonna be PJ?
PJ: I really want to get one now
Yea you wanna piss me off even further
[I think my dad is..]
*smacking the desk* FUCK
I
Mine was so much better
Fuck this game
And fuck you and fuck your dad
PJ: Hey how's it going guys
PJ: My name is PJ-pie
PJ: And the.. yeah this is my *laughs*
PJ: We're going to keep playing Google Feud (losing the words to laughter)
I love the taste of
*writes cum*
Damn It!
Pewds: what? !
PJ: Well you spelled his name wrong to start with.
Pewds: Did I?!
PJ: Yeaah
*typing*
PJ: No wait that's not right Pewds: That's how I spelled it, thats- oh you forgot the "e"
oh hoho!
another 10,000 in the pot for PJ
Shakespeare motherfuckaaaaaaa
Pewds: Can you just go? PJ: Alright alright Pewds: I'll keep playing this until I get a point
Okay so I'll be back at like 10 o' clock? 11 o' clock? Tomarrow maybe
I'll come back tomorrow alright Pewds: Shut up :V
Pewds: Yeah just yeah i'll take that I'll take
a healthy 9000
so how do you spell bieber ok thats how you spell bieber
you know you don't get that 10,000
points
Wow looks like i win it PJ thank you
all for coming along on the
fuck.....um
I think so which one did you like then
Felix we don't really know which one
which was your favourite?
I've always wanted a face tattoo
yeah i'll be like the girl that woke up
with
stars haha right yeah I remember that
woman had them going down
yeah that's hard to say very nice very
uh like you've never done this before
huh
that feels good you have good oh my gosh
[talking about how the glitter is never going away]
I'll i think this is I think it's just
it's just generally a messy thing you do
that
oh sure don't get in your eyes it really
hurts my neck all right just hold on for
a few more seconds okay lets make it even
make me look pretty
hit me up PJ yeah you got a nice little
dork and going ok I think I don't have a
group are you gonna sign it
I yeah Jesus Christ
I'm drying it
Ok
mum don't look at this video mum on the
big reveal huh
pull it pull like a band-aid oh look at
that
that's beautiful that is a thing of
beauty holy shit I look fucking awesome
Oh my God PJ are you jealous
a little bit yeah
these look these look at them again
oh there again oh now is shit this has
been google feud
PJ thank you for I'm never inviting you again
google feud has truly put us in a feud
exactly you want to find PJ check out
link in description
PJ? KickthePJ? That's the one KickthePJ that's the one
thanks man how long have we been friends now?
PJ: Not long enough Pewds: Too Long
and remember to leave a like if you
enjoyed the video and as always as we do
it
yeah
- kiss yes
are you playing Pokemon Go too?
only cause we saw you do it
catch anything good? to drive behind you do we
see the same pokemon seen ya series we
found all the same pokemon I it is so
cool its as if it's real or something
it's almost like the pokemon is there now he
just got hit by a car
yeah and we're gonna go to the seafront to
do some fishing
maybe I'll find some